many adults have been putting medical
care on hold because of covet concerns
but one local company is here to remind
you how important it is
to know about your health before signs
and symptoms appear
here's the preventative diagnostic
center
[Music]
hi i'm dr pierce dr john pierce i'm the
medical director here at preventive
diagnostics
the centers of disease control here in
the united states estimate that about 40
percent
of the american population has avoided
medical care
due to concerns of covet and this is
problematic
and we have diabetics that aren't
getting their treatments that aren't
following up with their doctors
we have people that are staying at home
suffering from chest pain
suffering from a heart attack and their
fear of getting covered
is such that they're afraid to go to the
emergency room
we have cleaners come in at night we
clean this place in between
patients all of our staff is following
all the recommendations and guidelines
personally people may be looking at me
saying well you're not wearing a mask
but i'm the only one in the room
basically
right and we've got plenty of social
distancing we've got great ventilation
so we're at a very very low risk
of having somebody come in and be sick
and transmit it to other people
this is a high definition ct scan
this scan is very unique compared to
pretty much any other scan in the valley
or in the state it
actually takes the patient's size into
consideration
and calculates the lowest effective dose
of radiation to give us superior imaging
we can find things down to the size of a
grain of rice
early diagnosis yields much better
prognosis
as a cancer survivor i'm always
interested in doing whatever it takes to
stay ahead of things you know i'm here
today because
i we caught the cancer early on so i
think it's really important
that you know we always look forward to
how to you know stay in on preventative
care
absolutely absolutely our our health is
is paramount
and staying on top of things is the
number one goal because you can't help
others if you don't take care of
yourself
people ask you know what kind of results
have you seen and i've had some
really really unique cases that have
come across
uh one that kind of points or stands out
to me
is a patient named mark he was a patient
in my other clinic
and uh and he was a patient here and so
we got his calcium score back it was
pretty high and i said hey i really
think you need to see a cardiologist and
discuss kind of
what your options are because of this
high calcium score
and he was a little reluctant but he did
it and
after he'd seen the cardiologist the
cardiologist gave me a call and
literally said you saved his life
because he had an 80
blockage here and a 90 blockage here
he's literally
was sitting on a time bomb in his chest
and so
you go wow that really made a difference
for more information call
hundred 702-534-7900 visit
pdcenterlv.com
they're offering you a heart scan with a
calcium score
for a hundred and twenty five dollars
that's normally
599 dollars las vegas now we'll be right
back